what is happening there reject nation
it's me dan dan seibert is back one of
the og
real rejects guest greg's next door
neighbor whom he never sees
that's the reputation you have also
streaming award winning editor
that's right one of the best editors in
all the youtube all right i gotta go
he's also got his own solo channel
called that cyber channel
recently passed a hundred thousand
subscribers he's been
killing it lately his videos are awesome
i sincerely mean that wonderfully edited
wonderfully scripted very informative
funny as hell i'm telling you guys their
unique ass video game
videos oh i was on such a good role
saying it and then i just
totally fumbled the ball there the basic
gist is i spend way too much time
editing yeah for your enjoyment please
watch my videos watch his videos he's
also on twitch never takes a break the
trailer he was most excited for at least
that's what i picked up from talking
with him
is metroid dread the announcement
trailer
dan let's just swing into action and
let's see if you can keep up with all
the
analyses and thoughts that i have
so basically i'll be doing the analysis
and everything afterwards
yeah basically i'll let you talk
basically what you take it
look let me get it out of the way the
graphics look good
[Laughter]
you haven't even hit play
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the suit looks so good
cool
whoa
yeah this is scary
i know go
go go
really capitalizing on that dread vibe
hell yeah
now it's all fun and games
yeah you love to see gameplay you love
to see gameplay it's not actual gameplay
footage
[Music]
it looks so good oh i hate that
[Music]
it's so good greg it's like a it's so
good badass
sci-fi horror but also fun for the whole
family
it's such a it's such a good direction
for metroid now dan i got so many things
i want to add on
in regards to the whole metroid
franchise yeah but why don't you
start okay the idea of taking metroid in
kind of like a more
horror-esque yes is such it's such a
it's a good fit have they not done that
before i mean
the whole there's been like hints of it
every now and then it's mostly been more
of like a sci-fi
kind of adventure sort of thing this is
the first time that they've really gone
into like the
hey by the way you can't kill those
things yes
and you're like wait what yeah
i'm sorry excuse me there's an element
of stealth that needs to be
added into it oh yeah they have that one
shot in the trailer where he
does go full stealth she would i say he
yeah i i thought i was skipping over the
pronoun gender and i uh
but i got the he in there i don't know
because look i was like oh i'm about to
say he but it's a [ __ ] so i'm just going
to skip it again
i know it's a she um samus
samus yes samus is a girl yes i know
boom i know some things
they're using the same engine that came
from
metro or not metroid samus returns which
was on the 3ds
it was the most recent one and it's a
very very good engine
mostly because you have the ability to
counter so if enemies get too close
rather than just like
randomly shooting and hope that they
don't kill you before you do it
yeah you slap them in the face and then
you shoot them nice it's
a really good mechanic yes it's a very
very good mechanic
i love the title the subtitle dread
because yes when i think of sci-fi
horror
usually with like think of like alien or
whatever even
the episodes of watching a lot of doctor
who lately whenever they go horror in
doctor who
the word that constantly comes to mind
is dread it's that dread-filled horror
yeah because it's the isolation of space
and the
unknown extraterrestrial elements that
you're going up against and that's what
took me for a loop here yeah it was
called metroid dread
but i was like oh damn this is gonna be
such an ominous tone the whole time
we're doing this yeah
yeah it's weird because it's creepy but
it's bright it still feels like the
nostalgic game but
it's not like spin on it yeah exactly
i'm glad they didn't go for like
everything's dark and like you have to
use like a flashlight now it's just like
hey there's an invincible monster that
can find you wherever you are yeah
better avoid that yeah it's like a scary
arcade game it's what it felt like
it feels like metroid it looks like
metroid the new suit is
awesome when i first initially saw that
she wasn't in her normal like
red orange suit that she always like
she's basically had since
uh metroid started and it was this sort
of like
blue white red mix it was kind of like
ah
then i kept looking i was like oh this
looks really good oh yeah that's really
good
i see you metroid prime 4 we didn't see
anything
i'll take this yes i'll go i'll i'll
gladly take this
no problem but how long has this metroid
dread game been in development because
i've heard about this dread game being
like
at least talked about for for ages ago
okay so one
because you know how much how much free
time i have
is that we're able to hang out i have a
hard time following rumors and that sort
of stuff and i heard
whispers about it towards the beginning
but uh most of the focus has been
on madrid 4 which essentially was being
developed it was announced
nearly four years ago i think and then
halfway through they went hey we noticed
that the game is not
up to quality so we're scrapping
everything it's starting over and so
we've all been like
cool i guess we'll wait then they go
like metroid prime four
we're still working on it but in the
meantime
awesome this looks great i can't wait to
go over to your place to place you never
invite me over to to maybe play the game
that i probably won't be able to play
you want to be there for the first
stream
yeah i'll see like bridgette jonathan
jerica all them over there
not me olivia
okay we can do without olivia
i'm kidding no she will attack me like
that alien attacking samus at the
beginning
i'm sorry
tackles you
all right guys thanks for being here
thanks and for saving the videos today
subscribe to dan's channel that cyber
channel
link in description box and pin comment
subscribe to the real rejects
where most of the time we know we're
talking about if we don't need a tanner
hit that like button and we'll catch you
guys soon so you leave your thoughts
down below
yeah comment um uh metroid dreads best
game ever
i thought it had something more fun
comment we're done we're done